ce n'était pas la classe dans laquelle
étaient cachés carlos ghosn japon une
caisse venu tout droit du japon et un
sens aigu de la mise en scène pour les
commissaires priseurs rouillac père et
fils habitué des opération fracassantes
il présente aujourd'hui à la presse
leurs nouveaux trésors rien de moins
qu'un tableau de claude monet
une rareté c'est un tableau assez
exceptionnel de voir en france parce
qu'aujourd'hui tous les tableaux de
claude monet qui apparaissent aux
enchères sont vendus à new york à
londres depuis dix ans sur quatre cent
cinquante tableaux seulement 14 se sont
vendues en france et donc c'est un
événement de présenter ce tableau
aujourd'hui au musée des beaux-arts de
tours ce tableau peint en 1882
représente une vue de la ville de dieppe
les techniques utilisées par le peintre
sont éblouissants un ciel extraordinaire
un premier plan dont le rouge vous
attire tout à fait naturellement et ses
feux titouan que sont autant de flèches
et un premier plan dont le rapport se
fait de verre en mélangeant sont bleues
sont jaunes pour ses touches vertes qui
sont un camaïeu de vert présenté cette
oeuvre exceptionnelle dans l'une des
salles du musée des beaux-arts de tours
était aussi un bon moyen de rap lire à
tous combien cette institution fermée au
public pour cause de qu'ovide depuis de
trop longs mois est impatiente de
pouvoir ouvrir ses portes
ça crée l'événement
on revoit des genres musée il serait
intéressant musée
on a envie effectivement dès voir
revenir de les voir s'émerveiller de la
même manière que les journalistes les
merveilles devant ce tableau donc oui ça
crée de l'ong se monnaie sera la pièce
maîtresse de la vente annuel des
commissaires priseurs
il sera mis aux enchères le 6 juin
prochain au château d'artigny avec une
mise à prix de 1 million d'euros
sauf aggravation des conditions
sanitaires les amateurs du monde entier
devraient s'y bousculer